hi Samuel Leeds here and in this video I
wanted to specifically address people
that are struggling with disappointments
maybe you've had a property deal fall
through maybe you just haven't had any
success and everything seems to be not
working out for you if that's you right
now then stay tuned well you know we're
living in a world certainly in a country
in England of absolute opportunity and I
don't think it's ever been easier with
the internet and with all the
opportunities that we have to become
financially free and to become
successful as it is right now in 2018
however that doesn't mean that it's
always really really easy it doesn't
mean that you're never gonna ever have
any objections obstacles disappointments
and one of the things that people
sometimes accuse me of is they say son
do you just make things sound far too
simple and the reason that I think
people say that about me is two reasons
number one I think that it is simple I
think they're becoming financially free
I think property investing I think
business is really easy most people make
it more complicated than it is I became
financially for it 21 with no
qualifications they it can't be that
difficult but I think we're the number
two is because I do make things simple
and I do try and make them even more
simple so that people actually do it my
mission is to see people doing stuff I'm
on a mission this year to help 50 people
become financially free I've helped 17
so far this year so I love that I get a
buzz from that and Tony Robbins says he
says that when he first started teaching
he used to make things complicated
deliberately to make himself feel and
sound intelligent and important until he
realized that complexity is the enemy of
execution and that even though he was
looking at intelligent his his students
weren't being successful and then he'd
realized that any idiot can make
something complex and they might have
their own agenda to make themselves
sound intelligent or to then sell you
something or whatever but actually it
takes a lot of skill to make something
simple so that's what I make things
sounds simple because they are and
because I want to see people succeeding
and I know that complexity is the enemy
of execution and I want you guys to
execute what you learn but I'm not going
to deny property investing it can be
very slow can be very mundane and it can
be very disappointing it can the things
can take a lot longer than you expect
things can sometimes be more expensive
than you hoped but I just want to I just
want to really take this opportunity to
say hang in there because the more
problems you have the more
disappointments you have the more
success you're gonna have and the more
celebrations you're gonna have I'm quite
well known for saying that first you
must learn to discipline your
disappointment and then you can
celebrate your success so whether you're
disappointed right now because you've
been being told no several times by
estate agents don't remember the more
nose you get the more yeses you're also
really going to get as well if you're
disappointed because your property fell
through three days before completion
which I had now three days before
exchanging my second deal it fell
through three days before exchanging and
I was absolutely gutted I was torn apart
the rules changed on me and I realized
that people that make the rules are the
same people that make money in property
so I just need to get more educated but
hang in there keep going because it can
happen it happens to us all in fact
myself true story
I think it was like three weeks ago now
my brother went to an auction and we
were we were bidding on a castle and I
did a video about actually in fact
there'll be a little button that will
come up here if you want to watch that
video right now but this what happened
was we visited up to eight hundred and
five thousandth which was our maximum
bid and then the other guy built it up
to 810 and we were like aren't man so we
had to walk away from the auction and I
was really really disappointed I did
about it I was really bummed out but
what happened was his purchase fell
through and the auction rang us back a
few days later and said do you want it
for 805 and I spoke to them and I said
how about how about 800 and they accept
it and I was just thinking thank God I
didn't continue bidding up and getting
wrapped up involved in some bidding war
like we could have ended up winning it
by spending hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of pounds more for the castle
so I did first I discipline my
disappointment but now I can celebrate
my success now as it happens that went
from bad to good in literally a few days
sometimes it could be a few weeks
sometimes it could be a few months but
whatever it is that you're going through
right now so you have got problems
disappointments what l say is just
educate yourself keep your head in the
game hang in there and get ready to
celebrate your success and I can't wait
to hear about your stories so on this
video I don't want to hear about your
problems and your disappointments
because that's boring I'm done with that
now but on this video I want you to this
post below pose
your biggest success this year so far in
property or even if it's not in property
because I never think is what you focus
on expands if you're always focusing on
the problem and you become you become a
crap magnet nothing works out for me
kind of person whereas if you if you
just accept it's gonna happen just
discipline it and move on and focus on
the successes then that's what manifests
more in your life so comment below with
your successes of the year so far
whether they're in probability or
elsewhere I can't wait to read them I'll
try and comment back and like everything
that I say god bless you see you next
week thank you so much for watching if
you benefit just on that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time